فشل مجلس النواب الامريكي في تمرير حزمه
مساعدات لاسرائيل تتجاوز قيمتها 17 مليار
دولار ولم يحصل مشروع قانون المساعدات على
اغلبيه الثلثين المطلوبه بعد ان صوت ضده
250 نائبا مقابل دعم 180 نائبا
فقط المزيد حول هذا الموضوع تنضم الينا
الان من واشنطن مراسلتنا بيسان ابو و ك ب
نرحب بك اسباب اذا وسياقات هذا الفشل كما
وصف سفيان كانت هذه الخطوه نوعا ما متوقعه
لان اداره بايدن حين طلبت ذلك الدعم
لاسرائيل بقيمه 17 مليار دولار كانت قد
وضعته ضمن حزمه اكبر لدعم ايضا لاوكرانيا
وتايوان واضيف على ذلك ايضا قضيه تامين
الحدود الجنوبيه مع المكسيك طبعا تلك
الحزمه تعطلت لاسباب متعدده منذ اكتوبر
الماضي ومفاوضات
متعدده فما قام به رئيس مجلس النواب
الجمهوري مايك جونسون هو المضي قدما اليوم
بهذا التصويت بفصل الاموال لاسرائيل عن
تلك الحزمه تزامن ذلك في وقت تمكن
المفاوضون في مجلس الشيوخ من ديمقراط
وجمهوري من التوصل
لاتفاق بشان الحزمه الاكبر التي تشمل ايضا
تمويل اوكرانيا والحدود وما الى ذلك
واسرائيل ف البيت الابيض من جهته
والديمقراطيون في مجلس الشيوخ وفي مجلس
النواب يدعمون تلك الحزمه الكامله لذا جاء
اليوم هذا الفشل في التمرير باصوات
ديمقراطيين قيادات الديمقراطيين زعاماتهم
في مجلس النواب بسبب تلويح البيت الابيض
باستخدام الفيتو اذا ما مر ذلك المشروع
ورفض مجلس الشيوخ اساسا التعامل مع هذا
التمويل بشكل منفصل عن الحزمه الاكبر التي
تتعامل مع قضايا امن قومي وتمويل اوكرانيا
طبعا في نفس الوقت هناك عدد ليس بقليل من
المشرعين الديمقراطيين المحسوبين على
الجناح تقدمي للحزب يرفضون هذا الدعم جمله
وتفصيلا سمعنا من النائبه رشيده طليب
سمعنا من النائب روكانا سمعنا من النائبه
الكساندريا اوكازيو كورتيز جميعهم يقولون
انهم سيرفضون
التصويت يعني وسيرفض بلا على هذه الحزمه
لانها بمثابه شك على بياض لاسرائيل
ونتنياهو وما قالته رشيده طليب وهو يرتكب
اباده في غزه بانه دعم غير مشروط دعم لا
يتضمن اي مساعدات انسانيه لقطاع غزه لذا
كان هناك نوعان ربما من التصويت في صفوف
الديمقراطيين الجناح الوسطي الذي يدعم
اسرائيل في الحزب ولكن ذلك الجناح ايضا
يريد تمرير دعم لاوكرانيا لذا رفض دعم
اسرائيل باعتبار ان هذه ليست الا لعبه
سياسيه من رئيس مجلس النواب وكل ذلك
لدواعي داخليه
الجناح الاخر رفضه لانه يرفض الحرب على
غزه وما تقوم به اسرائيل في تلك الحرب
وذلك الجناح التقدمي وننتظر اليوم تصويت
مجلس الشيوخ على الحزمه الاكبر التي ايضا
تواجه معارضه من الجمهوريين لاسباب داخليه
متعلقه بامن الحدود سسان ابو كويك من
واشنطن شكرا جزيلا
لك